[AUDIO OUT]
MATT BRITTIN: --I'm cold by the
standards of Sir Alex Ferguson.
[LAUGHTER]
What can you tell us about that?
RIO FERDINAND: Ha, ha.
No, you know what it was?
It was when I signed
for Manchester United,
my mum was in the--
[AUDIO OUT]
--after in a big--
black-- in a big room--
big hall.
All the families and stuff
were there, flown over
with the team.
[AUDIO OUT]
MATT BRITTIN: --your
upbringing as a child, as well.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I was always focused
on what I wanted to do.
I didn't care what anyone
thought about anything.
For instance, I
mean, on the estate
I grew up on, to talk about
got into ballet as a boy,
it was a--
you weren't done--
MATT BRITTIN: This is
Peckham, we're talking about.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
But again, even
in my household, I
knew that my mum
and dad loved me,
but they didn't
speak about love.
They didn't really
show affection.
My mum and dad-- simple
things, like never
sat on the same sofa.
I never saw them sit and
cuddle on the same sofa.
So I never had any idea of
how to show affection and love
in that sense.
My dad's showing love to
me was through traveling
to work in North London,
coming back to South London
to pick me up, and--
[AUDIO OUT]
MATT BRITTIN: --the person
you were when you met Rebecca.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: So she
didn't immediately
see you as somebody
that opened up to her.
Tell us little about
meeting with her,
and what turned
you on to the fact
that maybe this was
somebody different.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, she
didn't like football,
which was a good start.
[LAUGHTER]
She didn't want to talk about
anything to do with my career.
Didn't really have
any idea who I was,
until her friend told her.
Yeah, and I think that was
a great starting point.
And I think that when I
came home from football,
as we were together, and
years and years went by,
she didn't want to speak about
football, which was great.
I think a lot of
people would go home,
and people would talk
about football and stuff.
I wanted to just switch off
from that, as much as I could.
And it's difficult,
because a lot of people
think it's a glamorous life,
being a footballer's wife.
Listen, there are great
perks to do go with it,
but it's a lonely time, as well.
And what she was
willing to do was
to kind of put one
stage of her life
on hold, with the view
that when I retire,
we'll become a normal family
and do things together.
Because when the kids had
their six weeks holidays--
summer holidays--
and they were free to
go away and do stuff,
they would go on alone.
I was on tour in Asia, or
wherever I was with the team,
getting ready for the season.
Same as Easter.
Same as Christmas-- I was
training Christmas Day.
New Years, the same.
So that was all put
on hold, with the mind
that there was going to be
time when I retire to do that.
But we were never
afforded that time.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah,
because you got together
with Rebecca in 2000, I think.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: And
you then started
to think about your
retirement quite
early, as you might expect, with
somebody with so much focus--
other business interests,
restaurant, media career,
and so on.
So you're moving
towards that point.
You've moved back to
London, playing at QPR.
So you were really
looking for the next stage
to start, where you were
going to be much more part
of the family scene, I guess.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, and
that was the whole plan,
for many years.
And so then all of
a sudden, bang, you
get a bolt out of nowhere that--
cancer.
And you don't know what to do.
You're going-- we
were speaking before.
You just go into a blur,
and you just don't really
know what's hit you.
And I'm from a
background of sport,
where I can almost dictate
what happens, to some extent.
MATT BRITTIN: Control
all the controllables.
RIO FERDINAND: Control
everything, yeah.
And then this was just taken
straight out of my palm.
I could have no
control, whatsoever.
MATT BRITTIN: So can
we talk a little bit
about this, if we may?
So this is 2013,
and she's diagnosed
with quite an aggressive
form of breast cancer.
So that must have been--
and you have got, at that
point, three young children.
That must have been a real blow.
And you say you went
into sort of a blur.
Tell us a bit about that.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah,
well, I was driving home.
I remember perfectly--
I was driving home.
I was about two
roundabouts away from home.
And then I remember
Rebecca phoned,
and her voice was croaky.
And she told me she'd
been to the doctor's.
But again, I knew she was going
to the doctor's about a lump
in her breast.
But because I was so focused
and in a bubble of playing
football, and so focused
on being successful,
it didn't even come into
my mind when she phoned me.
And then when she said cancer,
your kind of world just kind
of stops, and you just--
I don't know.
It's hard to explain
what happens.
You just don't know--
all you're looking for is,
are you going to survive,
or are you not?
So we went to see
professors, doctors, etc.
And you're asking the
questions, and you walk in,
and you're in there for an hour.
And if anybody asked me what
I'd come out of that meeting
and learned, or listened
to, I wouldn't have
a clue of any of the detail.
Because all I wanted
to know was, is she
going to survive, or not.
And if I didn't get
a yes or no in that,
everything else was irrelevant.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
And you applied a kind
of a winner's mentality
to that period.
And fortunately, she did
get through breast cancer.
So it felt like you had got
through that terrible time,
and you'd come out
of it the other side.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
And for a good period of time--
I think it was 18 months--
she was fine.
She was in recovery.
Her hair was growing back,
and seemed healthy and fine.
And then all of a sudden,
bang, it comes back again.
And by this time I'd been back
in London playing for QPR.
And her sister called me when
I was on the way into training
and just said, listen, you'd
better come to the hospital.
Rebecca's been called
into intensive care.
It could be cancer again.
And by the time I got
there she was in a bad way.
And then from then it was
like six, seven weeks,
and she passed away.
MATT BRITTIN: Devastating.
The cancer had metastasized
into bone cancer--
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, everywhere.
MATT BRITTIN: And she
didn't come out of there.
Well, she came out once or
twice to visit home, I think.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: But that was
basically very, very quick
from the diagnosis
to the end for her.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, it was.
I mean, it showed the strength
of character, and of her, that
probably 48 hours--
two or three days
before she passed away--
it was my little
girl's birthday.
And she made--
I don't know where she
gathered the strength from--
but to come home.
And she half organized a party
for all of her school friends.
And she came, and was part
of that last celebration
of Tia's fourth birthday.
And then it was three or four
days later she passed away.
But she had terrible
nose bleeds.
Even people at the party who
hadn't been told, because she
was quite secretive
about it, they must
have thought something was up.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
And what did you tell the
children at this point?
Because they're pretty young.
RIO FERDINAND: Mm.
And that's the difficult part.
What do you tell them?
Do you tell them what the
full extent, and panic them?
And because you don't
know how long she's
going to stay alive-- is
she going to stay alive--
what do you say?
And Rebecca was
adamant that, listen,
just try and keep
everything normal.
Keep going to work.
Keep going out and
taking them to school.
Bring them here
every now and again.
Mummy's ill, but don't
give them the full extent
until we have to.
And obviously that day came,
where I had to tell them.
I mean, you wouldn't get
a harder day in your life
than having to tell your
three kids that they're never
going to see their mum again.
So to have to do that,
it's not an easy thing.
MATT BRITTIN: Absolutely.
And then you describe in
here how you have to pick up.
You've got to try
to get them to have
some kind of a normal life.
You had lots of
friends and family
around to try to help you.
But initially it was just like
getting people out of the door
for you, and trying to get
into some kind of a routine.
How was it, initially
for you, trying
to manage that sudden
enormous gap in your life?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, you
become the person they look to.
You become the leader in the
house, and the only person,
and the focal point
of their life.
Normally they've got two
of you to bounce off.
But being that person that
has to organize everything--
luckily I've got a good network
of people around me to help.
And I'm from a
background where--
in sport, especially in
football, it's like sheep.
I go to an airport, I
don't even look at a sign,
you just follow feet.
Do you know what I mean?
It's just, you
haven't got a doctor.
The doctor's in the
training ground.
So I've not got a
dentist anywhere,
the clubs sort that out.
So when you get thrown into
the situation that I was in,
you've got to find this kid's
doctor, the kids' dentist.
When do they go for
their checks, et cetera.
This was all on
autopilot before.
So there's so many
different things--
and then going to school--
that you've got to get your hand
on, and make sure that you've
got it all sorted out.
But yeah, it can
be overwhelming.
And that's when I spoke about,
in the book, where you--
I've never, ever
contemplated suicide.
But I'd always look to people
that had committed suicide
and thought, selfish people,
and never understood it.
But when I got to this point, in
the days, weeks, months after,
I'd sat there a few times and
understood exactly how and why
they'd got to that point.
I'd never-- I'm not saying I'd
ever contemplate it at all,
but I could understand.
And I said, without a
network of friends and family
that I had around me, you could
see it's easy for somebody
to slip into that state.
MATT BRITTIN: And you talk in
the book about reaching out
for help, and trying to
figure out when you're ready,
and when your family
is ready for that.
Can you tell us a little
bit about when you first
started realizing
that you needed
some help-- more than
friends and family
being around you to
help with the logistics?
RIO FERDINAND:
Well people always
said, oh, go and
see a counselor,
go ans see a therapist.
But again, that macho
sport environment
that I was born
into, and was into
would always shut
that away and say, no,
why am I going to
talk to somebody
who hasn't been through it?
It's like the only thing
I could think about.
Because they sent us
someone into the hospital.
When Rebecca was in
her last few days,
they sent a counselor
into the room.
I remember when the
lady walked out,
Rebecca said, well, you're
not going to see her again.
Because she asked her, has
anyone passed away from cancer
in your family?
And she said no.
And the only thing
you can liken it to
is going for a driving test
with a driving instructor who
hasn't passed their test.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
RIO FERDINAND: And that's the
way I was thinking about it.
And so once someone asked
me about the documentary.
And I thought, yeah, this
could be a great journey for me
to actually learn.
And quite a therapeutic journey
for me to go and see people.
So I went to a widower's meeting
with about seven or eight guys
who had been in my position.
Some six months in,
some 10 years in.
And I just learned so
much from these guys
that had been in my shoes
and walked my path already.
For instance, just when
is it right to take off
your wedding ring?
I was the only one sitting
there with a wedding ring on.
All of them were looking
at me like I was mad.
But everyone--
MATT BRITTIN: You
thought they were mad.
RIO FERDINAND: And I was
thinking, you're crazy.
I'm not the mad one.
You obviously didn't
love your wife then,
if you took your
wedding ring off.
That's how you think,
and you're judgmental.
But it's only with
time and speaking
to people you start
thinking, you know,
actually certain
things are natural.
And they are going to happen.
You're going to change.
Your feelings are
going to change.
Even the relationship.
MATT BRITTIN: A
couple of things you
said are kind of remarkable.
I mean firstly, your
approach to getting help
was to make a BBC documentary.
That probably
wouldn't be something
that most people would do.
But why did you choose?
Having been such a
self-described closed person,
you basically chose to make a
documentary about your grief
and your family.
RIO FERDINAND:
Yeah, I mean, I've
never done "Hello
Magazine," or "OK,"
and stuff like that
with my family,
or come into my
house type thing.
That was just so far
from what I was about.
But this was
something that I knew
would help my kids,
first and foremost.
They would be to visualize
something that would be easy
for them to digest,
and understand me
and the situation better, maybe.
Men-- help them to speak
out, because we're not
natural at doing
stuff like that.
No matter what
environment you're in,
whatever workplace you're in,
it's just not natural for a man
to kind of take down
that barrier or guard
and be a little bit softer.
And I realized the importance
of that, and how important
that could be.
And just opening
up to more people.
And what it's done is
enabled other people to--
I've been in supermarkets, old
ladies who I'd have thought
would never even know who I
am coming up to me and saying,
listen, give me a hug.
And I'm like, oh.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't think I
was that appealing.
But I've seen your documentary.
I heard your book's coming out.
And so it's enabled people--
MATT BRITTIN: And
what's it meant
to those-- you've got some
notes, actually in here,
from people who say thank
you for the documentary.
It meant lots of different
things to those people,
hasn't it?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
Some people just
would come up to me,
and I haven't spoke for five
years-- my mum passed away five
years ago, and never spoke.
I couldn't.
But I watched your
program, and I
heard about your
book coming out,
and it's enabled me to speak--
or feel free to speak openly.
And that's what the
purpose of it was.
That's the most rewarding
part of doing this.
MATT BRITTIN: So that forced
you into this journey of going
and trying some things.
And then the second
thing you said
there was that you found
talking to other people who'd
been through exactly what you've
been through the most helpful.
So maybe tell us a bit
about those stories
that opened you up a bit.
RIO FERDINAND: Obviously
the memory jar-- anyone
who saw the documentary,
the memory jar
was such a huge thing, because
I was finding it very difficult
to understand or work out where
my children were mentally,
emotionally.
MATT BRITTIN: So the
memory jar was this idea
of writing down memories.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, so I saw a
girl from Child Bereavement UK.
I went to watch some children
having a counseling session.
And one of the
things that came up
was that this young
girl called Emily
said that introducing the memory
jar-- where you write memories
of the person that's passed
away, and put it into the jar.
So it could be the
person's favorite color.
It could be anything.
Anything as small as that,
to the perfume they wear,
et cetera.
And I thought, well, I'll
take that back to my kids.
Because, my boys especially, I
couldn't get through to them.
Didn't know how
they were feeling.
And for a parent
to not understand
how your kids are feeling
is quite a bad place to be.
So once I introduced
the memory jar to them,
it was like everything
just opened up.
They became so much more
happy talking about their mum
immediately.
This is her favorite
song, singing her song.
And just things that just
kind of open you up and think,
you know, actually
I'm getting something.
I can breathe a
little bit easier.
So that was a huge thing.
But also when I went
to Ireland to see
Darren Clarke, who's a golfer.
There's a lot of parallels.
He is a sportsman.
His boys were a
similar age to my boys
when his wife passed away.
And he was the first person that
actually made me sit and think,
yeah, there is a life after.
And he was saying, listen, I
can see you're not smiling.
You don't look happy.
But one day you will be.
I'm living proof.
I'm as happy as I
was ever before.
I never, ever
thought I could be.
You're sitting there
thinking that, Rio.
I've been there.
But I am happy.
Trust me.
You will be happy one day if
you let yourself open yourself.
And so at that point that
was the first time thought,
you know what, maybe I will be.
And allowed myself to
be a lot more open.
And I think if
somebody had asked me
before going to
Ireland, will I be open
and have a full blown
relationship with someone?
Will I introduce that
person to my children?
Will I be public
with that person?
No chance.
I'd have stood on a stone
wall and said, no way,
I ain't doing that.
It will never happen.
I wouldn't do that to my kids.
What will people
think is a disgrace?
They will say I didn't love my
wife as much as I should have.
But he gave me
almost that clearance
to say, no, it is doable.
MATT BRITTIN: I think
you start the chapter
where you go and see
Darren Clarke by saying,
I'm flying back from
Ireland and I've
got a big smile on my face.
And it's a genuine smile
for the first time.
And there's also
a sense, though,
that he kind of made you
realize how important it
was for you to be happy again
for the sake of your family.
I think he says here,
in the long run,
your kids will only
get through this
if they see you smiling again.
If you love your
kids-- and I know
you do-- you need
to do it for them.
Almost like that
gave you permission
to move on and
start this journey.
RIO FERDINAND: Yes.
MATT BRITTIN: And the sense of
the memory jar on your children
is incredibly powerful.
The family started to
almost come to life
again, really, for
you at that point.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, definitely.
It's just so right.
I mean now I'm
living proof of that.
An example of that.
That I actually can
see that my kids are
happier when they see me happy.
And it is quite an obvious
thing, when you think about it.
But when you're in that bubble,
when you're in that situation,
you don't see things as clearly.
You need someone to
sometimes spell it out.
And that's why,
throughout the book,
I always keep saying
it's so important
to talk, and to
release your emotions,
so that somebody can give
you a bit of feedback
so you can learn again.
MATT BRITTIN: And
you said, also,
your children were dealing
with it in different ways.
Obviously they're different
ages from 11 through to--
RIO FERDINAND: Six.
MATT BRITTIN: --six.
And some were more open
and talking about Rebecca,
and some were not.
But the memory jar
brought you all together.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
I mean, my oldest
boy, Lorenz, he was--
if you talked about his
mum, he'd just walk off.
He'd get up and walk off.
Or he would just sit there
and just look through you.
And when you're a
parent, and you're
trying to talk to your
kid about how you feeling?
And because I was always
approaching it with quite--
without wanting to be, but
it's almost a depressive tone.
How you feeling today?
You thought about mum?
And I didn't know, but
I realized quickly after
the memory jar-- if you can
speak to them in a happy way
and make them feel--
because if you-- what about mum,
and the jokes she used to say--
they're so much more
open to talking.
Obviously, it's a depressing
thing to talk about.
And if you take that into the
conversation with the kids,
they just want to run a mile.
So it's the memory jar.
And I think them
seeing bits of--
I was lucky that BBC gave me a
few edits of the documentary,
condensed into a few
minutes, that they
could get to see a few things.
Seeing me cry, even.
Because I tell them,
listen, it's OK to cry.
But they need to
see it sometimes.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
RIO FERDINAND: So little things
like that have been so helpful.
And that's why it's been so
important to write this book,
but also the documentary.
MATT BRITTIN: And the book is
published this week, I think,
isn't it?
RIO FERDINAND: Tomorrow.
MATT BRITTIN: So you've
got copies at home,
and they've had a look at the
fact that dad's written a book?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah,
they were just happy
that they're on the front cover.
Just asking, why aren't
our faces are on there?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: They always
want something else.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah,
they want more.
MATT BRITTIN: We're
going to have time
to take a few questions.
So if you want to
ask questions to Rio,
then please do come to the mics.
And while you're doing
that, Rio, you also
talk in the book a little
bit about the conversations
you did and did not
have with Rebecca
when she was very clear that
it was going to end for her.
Can you us a little
bit about that, and how
you look back on that time now?
Whether there are things you
might have done differently.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah,
I think, again,
because I was so
emotionally closed,
and I'd never seen love
in a cuddly feely way,
I could never show it.
And the times that I
was up late at night--
especially the early times--
and feeling guilt and
regret, was about me.
Did I show enough love?
Did Rebecca know enough
how much I loved her?
I didn't allow her to
speak about even death--
about passing away.
She used to say to me, listen,
if something does happen,
I'm not here, let's
talk about what happens.
And I'd say, what are
you talking about?
And that's that sport mentality.
Defeat-- you can't talk
about defeat with this.
It does nothing.
I've never done that in my life,
so I ain't going to start now.
And you're going to waste
energy on talking negatively?
I can't do it.
But if I had it again-- and
I was unfortunate enough
to have the situation come again
with my mum, not so long ago.
And I spent many
days in the hospital
talking about what she wants.
Writing lists.
Even her funeral--
writing out everything
she wanted, from the music, to
the people she wanted there.
But I felt so much
better and clearer,
and don't have the moments
of thinking about what
my mom would want now.
Because I learned
from the first time.
MATT BRITTIN: I mean,
unfortunately you
had the opportunity to put
those lessons into practice just
as you finished the
book, as you say,
with the loss of
your mother, as well.
And you've also got a bunch
of other lessons you think--
very simple, but
very powerful lessons
that you've learned
through this process,
that you've tried to
share with other people.
Are there other things
that you'd say, absolutely,
people should do this more?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, I think
one thing is quite important, as
well, is when you go to see
the professor, or the doctor
for the information
of a diagnosis,
or what your next steps are,
is to always take someone who
is a little bit detached from
you guys as a little bit,
so you could come in and take
information-- take notes.
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
RIO FERDINAND: Like
I said before, you
go into that situation,
you walk in--
if someone was doing
a test and started
asking you questions on what was
said, you wouldn't have a clue.
You wouldn't-- because all
you're going in there really
for is an answer
to your question.
Which is, is the person
I'm sitting next to going
to survive, yes or no?
And everything else around
that becomes a blur.
So if someone said to me,
what did Rebecca pass away of?
What was the diagnosis?
I would have been sitting
there with a blank expression.
I wouldn't have a clue.
Didn't have any idea
what had happened.
But that's just natural.
The mind and body just goes
into kind of a mad state
and wants answers.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah,
You can't possibly
be detached from anything
like that, of course.
And you say in the book,
the heartbreaking thing
is that losing Rebecca
has made me more loving.
And I think you can see
that from some of the things
you've said there.
So if you could go back to that
bar in 2000 when you met her,
is there any advice you'd
give to your younger self,
or you would give
to your children
now, that's different you think?
RIO FERDINAND: My chat up
line would have been better.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
It seemed to work pretty well.
RIO FERDINAND: It worked,
but it wasn't a good one.
[LAUGHTER]
But yeah, being more open,
and just making the person
that you are with know
and understand how much
you do care about them.
I think that's a big thing
that I'd never done before,
and I want to make sure that
I don't make that same mistake
again in my relationship.
But also in my relationship
with my children.
So they know exactly
how much their dad does
love them and care about them.
And discipline, obviously,
but with a soft touch.
MATT BRITTIN: Discipline
with a soft touch.
I can imagine there's quite,
quite clear discipline
in the house.
Is that fair?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: And you also
touch on, in the book,
your relationship
with your own father.
And obviously that's changed
again recently, particularly
with the loss of your mother.
How has that changed you?
Because you've seen, as
a dad yourself, but also
seeing the world through
your father's eyes.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, and that's
been a great thing as well,
especially during the book.
Because I've got to kind of
work out why I am how I am.
Because I've had to look
back at my dad's upbringing
a bit deeper, to find out why my
emotions are the way they are.
My dad was a very hard,
tough to talk to person.
Discipline was high on his list.
And again, he didn't
show much affection
in the way that was able
to be seen immediately.
So it's just been good that--
in a roundabout bad way, but
I don't have to explain that--
but since the tragedies that
have gone on in our lives,
my dad has really stepped up
to the plate and become softer.
Become a great dad--
the one that I knew was there,
but in a more visual way.
I can see it.
And the kids can see it.
And it's testament
to him, really.
And I mean, even
the little things.
I see my sisters,
who are like 16--
twins.
They sometimes answer
my dad back with--
or roll their eyes at things.
And I think, whoa,
you are lucky.
[LAUGHTER]
Because that wouldn't
happen in my time.
So he's softened a
lot, in the right way.
MATT BRITTIN: It strikes me, a
lot of what you talk about now,
and you write about, and comes
through in the documentary
is about men.
And how we are.
And how we maybe should be.
Have you got a bigger
conclusion on that?
You think about all of
the locker room stuff,
and the training, and the
way you were as a sportsman,
surrounded by men all striving
to be brilliant at something.
There's something
bigger here going on
about men, maybe in Britain,
or maybe in the world.
RIO FERDINAND: It's hard.
Someone else asked
this me this year.
But then it's hard to
answer it without knowing
the answer here.
Because I always think
if I was a little less
intense, could come home and
detach myself from the game,
and be more chilled
out about it,
be more emotionally open in
and around the training ground
or at home, would
that been a negative
on me being successful
as a football player?
And I grew up
believing it would.
So I was scared to do that.
I wouldn't do it.
Because all I wanted
was to win trophies.
Whether it would be
playing for Man United
or winning table tennis
against one of the other boys,
I had to win.
So it's weird.
Obsessive, maybe.
But I think balance is the key.
I think you have to
find a right balance.
And I think towards the end--
when I had children I
probably had a better balance.
Because at the beginning,
if I had lost a game,
and friends would
come up from London,
I'd just say, pfft, I'm
staying in the room.
You can do what you
guys want, but I'm--
MATT BRITTIN: In the
book you actually say
that people will come up to
go out for a meal with you.
You'd lose, and you'd
just lock yourself away
until 4:00 in the morning.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: Is that
really what you'd do?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
So they'd come up,
expecting a great night
out, and some lovely
food somewhere in town.
And we'd lose, or
I'd played rubbish--
not often, but--
[LAUGHTER]
And then I'd go, and I'd just
walk in, and they'd just know.
Rebecca would have told them
already, on the way home.
They've lost, pfft, he
ain't gonna go out anywhere.
And I'd just go in the
room, and just sit there,
and just look at the telly.
And she'd walk in,
and I'd just go, ah.
And it's just the way it was.
I couldn't help it.
And it wasn't really until I
had kids that you-- you come in,
put your key in the door,
and you've got a kid there.
And you have to
change a little bit.
You've got to soften up
a little bit, but still.
The good thing about football
is that there was a game three,
four days later.
So it would only last
a couple of days--
MATT BRITTIN: Right.
RIO FERDINAND:
--that crazy feeling
of walking down the school path.
Or you would go into the local
newsagent's to buy a paper,
and you're looking at
the man behind the till,
thinking you'd better
not say anything.
[LAUGHTER]
I know you're a City fan.
Don't speak, please.
And then you get the
next game, you win,
and that emotion is gone.
MATT BRITTIN: And
what's been the reaction
from football fans to
this private side of you
that they've now seen?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, it's
broken down a lot of barriers.
I mean, especially
on social media.
You might be a Manc, I hate
you, but you're all right.
I saw the documentary.
I'm a Liverpool fan.
Put that aside.
You're not bad.
So it's broken
down a lot of that.
Because football's so tribal.
And it's taken something
like this to maybe--
people to see a
different side of me.
But I understand
that, listen, I didn't
like Liverpool when I played.
I didn't like Chelsea.
I didn't like Man City.
I could go on, really.
There's a lot of
teams I didn't like.
MATT BRITTIN: Yes, we could
list every team, but OK.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
MATT BRITTIN: But last chance
for questions, if anybody does
want to come.
What about now?
What what's driving you,
motivating you today?
You've got this whole
new track of being
that sort of go-to guy for
men should have more emotions,
and grief, and all of the stuff
that's contained in the book.
But you're also-- you've got
a very successful TV career.
And you're doing other
sporting stuff as well.
So what's driving you today?
What's next for you?
RIO FERDINAND: Just to be busy.
I think it was a bit of a
defense mechanism at first.
I said to my management company,
listen, make sure I'm busy--
I'm working hard to keep my mind
off of the negative thoughts.
I've kind of got
through that stage now,
but I still want to remain
focused, and stay busy
in the things I like to do.
And obviously the TV stuff
is great, being a pundit.
Running the YouTube
channel is great as well.
But I just like being busy.
And I like doing fun things,
and stuff that I enjoy.
And I'm lucky that I'm in a
position where I can do stuff
that I want to do.
I'm not forced to have to
do things I don't enjoy.
MATT BRITTIN: OK.
And we might come back at
the end and talk about one
of those things.
Henry's here with a question.
AUDIENCE: Rio, many
thanks for coming in.
A slight change of
direction, if I may.
Obviously, you were in a
highly successful team,
and you had also a highly
successful boss in Fergie.
And that perhaps
wasn't quite the case
in terms of your England career.
Obviously we never won any
silverware for a good while.
What's your point of view
on the England team today,
and the boss, and
looking forward
to next year's World Cup?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: Change of tone.
RIO FERDINAND: All right.
The England team.
Listen, I was talking to
Steven Gerrard the other day.
I work with him on telly.
Who I didn't like
for many years.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: He's
kind of all right.
RIO FERDINAND: He's
all right now, yeah.
And we were saying,
I'd love to get
a hold of this England team.
If I was a manager now.
You've got all the rough
tools of a decent team.
You've got pace, youth,
hunger, aggression.
They're tools you'd love to
start with and work with.
But it's about the manager
putting it all together.
I'm from an area
where they called
us the golden generation.
And on paper we probably had
the best collection of players,
on paper.
But we weren't put
together right.
We didn't produce the
performances, either.
And we never won anything.
I think it's too early
for this England team
to be considered
tournament winners.
But in years to come, with
what's coming underneath--
in the younger teams, that
are winning tournaments now,
I think there is--
with the right guidance,
there is an opportunity for us
to become a bit more
successful than we've been.
MATT BRITTIN: That's
quite diplomatic.
RIO FERDINAND: Yes,
this is life, isn't it?
So--
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: Another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rio.
RIO FERDINAND: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Going back to dealing
with grief, and the friends
and family around you, my
daughter's best friend's
father died recently of
cancer, after struggling
with it for a year.
And I'm finding it difficult
to relate to her friend again.
To know my position as,
you know-- because she
comes for sleepovers.
And how do I behave?
Do I remind her of her dad?
Does that make her unhappy?
Should I step back?
Do you have any sort of
advice for the friends,
and the parents of
friends of your kids,
that you've seen work well?
And what's actually
helped your kids?
MATT BRITTIN: Great question.
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah, that's
a good question, actually.
I think it's important
that you don't--
when her name comes up,
you don't stand like this,
like a rabbit in the headlights.
I think you've got to
be as calm, and cool,
and collected you can
around the subject.
But like I said before, I think
talking in an upbeat jovial way
is key.
And funny memories are
probably a good starting point.
What I used to like to do--
what we used to do [INAUDIBLE]
you're doing
something, and you can
remember that their parent
used to do that as well.
What about when mummy or
daddy used to do this?
I think it's so much easier
than rather than saying, oh,
how are you?
Kids get scared of
things like that, often.
They clam up, and close up.
And they think, well, who
are you asking me that?
What are you asking me that for?
And so I just think that kids
talking about their parents,
I think, is something
that is needed.
It's just picking
the right time,
and making sure you do
it in the right tone.
MATT BRITTIN: Right, thank you.
RIO FERDINAND: Cheers.
MATT BRITTIN: Another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Rio.
RIO FERDINAND: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I just had a question
about the world of football.
Because obviously
it's been your life.
But it's also-- a lot's said
about how it's a man's world,
and it's quite a
tough place where
people don't show emotions.
How was the world
of football for you
during the whole experience?
Did it help?
Did it not help?
And do you think
it needs to change?
It needs to be more
about sharing emotions?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah
well, [INAUDIBLE],,
the manager, and
probably [INAUDIBLE],,
and Bobby [INAUDIBLE],,
when I was at QPR,
were the only people that knew.
Bobby actually traveling
with every day,
so he'd hear me on the phone.
So I had to tell him I
was talking about, really.
Because he probably
worked it out himself.
And [INAUDIBLE],, we used to
have saunas and stuff together.
It sounds really weird.
But we used to--
[LAUGHTER]
--in a controlled environment
at the training ground,
used to just have
saunas, and we'd talk.
So I told him.
But the managers
obviously had to know.
But I used to find
the training ground,
and being in the
football club, a bit
of a place of where it
was respite, really.
It was a place of release,
where I wasn't being
looked at with any sympathy.
I didn't want that sympathy.
I didn't want people
to be thinking, oh,
is he all right, type thing.
Because that
becomes a strain, on
not only myself, but everyone.
So I wanted to keep
that to one side.
And it was a place where
I could go and relax
a little bit for that
hour or two in the day.
And because Rebecca wanted
me to keep going every day,
to make sure things seemed
normal for the children,
it was a blessing
really, in that sense.
But like I said before,
it's the balance.
You want people to be able to
share emotions as human beings,
but if it's at the detriment
of you winning trophies,
then there's the balance.
And said I always
wanted to win trophies,
so I don't know if I'd
have changed the way I was,
if it meant I wasn't
going to win trophies.
MATT BRITTIN: And let's come
back to that balance then.
We've just got, really, just one
minute left on this livestream.
So defender to contender.
This is a way that
you're channeling
some of your aggression now.
Just tell us a bit about that.
The world of boxing,
is that next for you?
RIO FERDINAND:
Yeah, weird, I know.
But my management just had
a phone call to say, listen,
would Rio accept this
challenge of trying
to become a professional boxer?
And when they asked me, I was
like, you know what, let's go.
And everyone I spoke
to said, you're mad.
What are you doing?
But I missed competing.
I missed that
one-to-one challenge.
I lived all my life kind of
competing, me against you.
Number nine, number
10, whoever you are,
me fighting against you to win.
And training the same
thing every day, for years.
And I've missed
that competition.
I miss it.
And for three years
I've not had it.
I've been offered to walk up
mountains, and stuff like that,
but that's not the man-to-man
one-to-one challenge
that I miss.
So I'm happy to get involved.
And mentally, as well.
Can you do it?
And I'm an armchair boxing fan.
I'll sit there saying,
I'd knock him out.
[LAUGHTER]
There's no way.
That looks so easy.
But now I'm going to
have the opportunity
to find out how hard it
is mentally, physically.
Can you get up at 5:00 AM
every morning, go on runs,
and take pounding?
MATT BRITTIN: It's a personal
challenge, rather than
the next great
career, you think?
RIO FERDINAND: Yeah.
I'm 38 years old, I'm not
going to be sticking around
for ages trying to be a boxer.
But my kids are
probably the people
that are putting the
most pressure on.
Because my boy said,
when I told him,
oh, that's a sick idea,
dad, wicked brilliant.
And the other one said,
yeah, but don't lose,
because it's embarrassing, dad.
[LAUGHTER]
MATT BRITTIN: Rio, I guess--
I think your kids are probably
incredibly proud of you
in so many ways.
And not just in
the sporting arena.
I want to say a huge thank you
for coming, and writing what
is an amazing, amazing book.
And thanks for sharing
your time with us.
RIO FERDINAND: Thank you.
MATT BRITTIN: Rio Ferdinand.
[APPLAUSE]
RIO FERDINAND: Thank you.
Cheers.
MATT BRITTIN: Thanks.
RIO FERDINAND: You're welcome.
MATT BRITTIN: Thank
you very much.
RIO FERDINAND: Cheers.
[INAUDIBLE]
MATT BRITTIN: Let's take
a photograph before we go.
A photograph for everybody.
Not me.
RIO FERDINAND: With you.
MATT BRITTIN: Just you.
RIO FERDINAND:
Thank you, cheers.
MATT BRITTIN: Thanks very much.
Thank you.
Thanks, everyone.